they are willing
they are able
[Applause]
but the military can't fully replicate
the work of the ambulance staff who are
the next to walk out in England and
Wales so this top button will be
deploying all right
a plea from the NHS to the public is
simple don't add to our burden
imagine Sam has the patient breathe in
tomorrow is not a day to have an
accident or to need Urgent Care funding
normally if you think you have an
emergency which isn't life-threatening
then start by using 111 online if that
doesn't give you the answer you require
then please phone 111
and if you think you need to go to
hospital then perhaps it would be a good
idea this evening to ask a friend or a
relative whether they would be able to
take you to hospital should the need
arise tomorrow
the system is already straining the cues
in stevenage are replicated already in
so many hospitals around the country
there is a real nervousness within the
health services to how this plays out
just how many people will be left
without the care that they need it is an
intensely difficult moment for the NHS
just at the point when they need their
staff the most
for their strike paramedics in Yorkshire
supported the nurses who were back out
for a second time that Leeds General
infirmary this was the Christmas
get-together nobody wanted how much
appetite do you have for doing this
again in January February
the Royal College of Nursing say they
have to be paid better the Westminster
government so they can't pay better I
believe Knight incumbent on the Prime
Minister on the 8th of Christmas to get
behind these nursing staff and patients
and do the decent thing get into a room
and start to talk to me thank you if
I've been uh yes the health secretary
insists he wants to do it we're keen to
talk we're engaging with the trade
unions on pay we have an independent
process and we have accepted that in
full and of course that comes on top of
the extra prioritization of the NHS last
year but we also alongside that need to
focus on patients I'd rather forward and
back and we're already now into the
negotiations around next year's pay
review body that starts at from April
we've already submitted the letter in
terms of that so that process is always
already underway
they all know that this is unsustainable
it really can't go on but without a
compromise it will
Tom Parmenter Sky News Leeds